Ali Wong filmed her first intimate scene
for beef I picked most of it as scripted
can you imagine the nerves but more than
that she struggled with just how much
she related to the character of Amy the
shoot was so stressful that she and
Steven even broke out into hives on the
final day now this is everything that
went on behind the scenes of beef as you
can already tell the filming for beef
was tough on our Stars Ali was even
reduced to real tears when she was
filming the scene where Amy talks with
her therapist about her insecurities as
a wife and mother I relate to this so
much Ali was tripped up on a long speech
that Lee wrote and although he didn't
say you have to cry she says that I just
ended up crying even Lee was surprised
that it only took Ali two takes of this
difficult scene to channel the right
emotions even noticing that she'd gotten
hives she was so connected to the
character and not only did Steven and
Ally get hives again when filming
wrapped we said that we all cried but
Ali cried for a long time I think she
was holding a lot of the pain of the
character in and it all came pouring out
well it definitely helps to have the
right inspiration did you know that beef
was inspired by an actual example of
road rage series Creator Lee sung Jin
was just driving along one day when he
encountered a white BMW not a Mercedes
like the one Amy drives on the show the
driver honked at Lee cursed at him and
drove away and Lee says that for some
reason on that day I was like I'm gonna
follow you can you imagine now of course
Lee says that it didn't end like it did
in the show but it did give him the idea
to write the script because of this
whole encounter Lee first pictured Ali's
character as more of a Stanley Tucci
type more like the guy who had actually
cursed at Lee but he eventually got
around to thinking that it might be more
interesting to see a woman in the role
and of course he let every actor add
their own personal touch there's a lot
of Stephen in Danny's character Lee
built the character of Dany with help
from Steven Young putting their heads
together to include details from
Steven's life into Danny's like the fact
that both Stephen and Danny emigrated
from Korea when they were young and the
fact that they both performed in a
crazed team at a Korean church group
growing up this would allow the actors
to have more say in what the characters
did like when Steven sent Lee a tape of
himself singing Amazing Grace that gave
him an idea for a scene but in other
cases the personal details were more
aesthetic like in the case of production
designer grace young actually visiting
Ali's house for inspiration a lot of the
inspiration of Amy's house happens to be
from my own home now can we just take a
personal moment here to remind you to
hit that subscribe button if you're
enjoying our video before we get back to
what we said about that Amazing Grace
moment how great was Steve Young's
Amazing Grace performance who knows he
could sing in fact what we see in the
show is even a live performance backed
by Justin min's brother leading an
actual praise band as well as a bunch of
real people from a Korean Church in
Pasadena it's pretty impressive when you
think about it although it's even more
impressive when you consider that they
only had one week to shoot all of the
church stuff that appears in every
episode executive producer Jake schreier
described it as a special week on the
show admitting that he had very little
connection to the Korean church but
Stephen who as we previously mentioned
grew up in it though it all felt very
real and that it had captured what he
wanted it to feel like we have to admit
it was a nice break from all the petty
Revenge Amy and Danny got pretty Savage
in their acts of revenge against each
other between Dany urinating on Amy's
bathroom floor and Amy leaving Danny bad
Yelp reviews things got pretty bad and
yet it could have been a whole lot worse
writer Alice Jew suggested this one idea
where Amy learned about a type of
psychology Warfare known as zersetzung
from Jordan and this would have led into
her just subtly messing with Danny's
life moving things around in his
apartment using up his toiletries just
little things like that that would have
eventually made Dany feel like he was
losing his mind Lee admitted that this
was a great idea but said that It
ultimately didn't fit within the
episodes and so the idea was scrapped we
imagined that something like this would
have made it just a little harder for us
to see that reconciliation at the end
how cute was that ending it was actually
Ali of all people who suggested over a
zoom meeting between Lee and the rest of
the cast that Amy should crawl into bed
with Dany and the second she did Lee
thought oh wow that's really beautiful
no other endings were considered from
there but when it came time for Lee to
actually write the script it was in the
middle of shooting while Lee was sick as
a dog with kovid Lee was still sick when
he went to direct the scene and that was
the first scene that Lee had ever
directed in his life apparently Lee's
assistant had to walk around with his
face on an iPad just so that he would be
able to see what was going on this
production was definitely a tough one on
its creator but he wasn't the only one
facing firsts we mentioned that beef had
its fair share of Firsts for Ali too
right I had my first intimacy scene
but apparently it wasn't all that big of
a deal for her no because there's like
there's so many people behind the camera
did you know that the scene where Amy
can be seen getting down and dirty with
a gun was actually inspired by a Moment
from The Sopranos we're talking about
the time that Richie holds a gun on
Janice in an intimate moment Lee is a
huge fan of The Sopranos and used it as
sort of a guide for the way he wrote the
characters on beef especially when it
came to the way that The Sopranos wrote
their characters where every time they
do something horrible you just have to
have some sort of glimpse of humanity
for the audience to then forget and that
isn't all Lee was also tempted to borrow
The Sopranos body count yeah you thought
beef got pretty dark it could have
gotten a whole lot lot worse the first
time that Lee put together an outline
for the show he says that there were way
more deaths just like deaths everywhere
it was apparently even so bad that
anyone who read the outline would be
like we you okay and even the show's
producer came to him like Hey buddy the
studio and network were the ones to say
we love it but maybe not everyone dies
which forced Lee to go back and consider
what was really important to each of our
characters for Dany it's his brother and
for Amy it's George this gave him a
better idea of what the show was going
to be about emotionally yet it isn't
only the writing that builds a character
it's also the clothes Ally wasn't a big
fan of her costumes as you might think
although she found that all the neutral
colors and shapeless clothes went a long
way towards establishing the kind of
class Amy wants to be associated with
she said that wearing them sort of felt
like a cage and she wasn't even supposed
to feel like that according to Ali she
felt like Amy chose these clothes and
yet they were like the person she wants
to be be and someone who she's not the
head of the costume Department Helen
Huang had this idea early on that Amy
would wear these clothes that are
seemingly Zen and neutral but then she
has these insane thoughts so we can
definitely see what Ali means when she
says that there's a disconnect between
Amy and her clothes but Danny's costumes
were all him now Danny is sort of Amy's
opposite in like every way they bring
out the best and the worst in each other
making their own Darkness conscious but
more on that quote later while Helen
sourced Amy's clothes out of every
online boutique Under the Sun most of
Danny's costumes were bought from
Goodwill this is because Helen sort of
Saw Dany as the sort of guy who stopped
stressing himself when he was 24 or 25
and so he'll only buy something new if
he has to replace something worn out but
it was Danny's pants which range between
really really old Dickies and really old
Pumas that made Steven go I know who
this person is Helen's brothers were all
skaters when they were young and so she
really wanted Danny to have a touch of
some sort sort of interest in a
different subculture were you able to
recognize the famous quotes every
episode's title is a reference to one
but there was one quote in particular
that Lee said was something of a driving
force to the entire show that one is
none other than the title to the series
finale which is a callback to Carl Jung
who said one does not become enlightened
by imagining figures of light but by
making the darkness conscious that
sounds pretty deep yet Lee sees a lot of
truth to it adding that in my own life I
find that I've only grown up when I
really look at the darkness in me other
episodes are references to Classic
filmmakers like episode 1 the birds
don't sing they screech in pain which is
borrowed from Werner herzog's
documentary burden of Dreams or else
they may be references to writers like
Sylvia Plath between Lee's actual road
rage and Steven's real life story
informing dany's you can really tell
that everyone behind the scenes brought
a lot of themselves to the show so which
of these details were you most surprised
by make sure to let us know in in the
comments section down below